Welcome to this deep dive, where you and I will open up a spiritual ethos of Islam, Reza Shakazami's reading of the sayings of the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him.
We are going to follow 4 startling words into how the created world hides God only by revealing him.
The veils do not veil him.
Yeah, to really grasp the sheer earth-shattering force of that idea, we have to look directly at the agonizing paradox of your own spiritual reality.
Because it's a paradox that sits entirely at the dead center.
of the human experience.
I mean, we really have to start with the crisis here.
We absolutely do.
And we have to frame this crisis carefully because it isn't just some abstract philosophical puzzle to solve.
It is something you feel in your bones every single day.
A literal ache.
Yes, an ache.
The scripture tells us in no uncertain terms that God is closer to you than the vein in your own neck.
And it insists that wherever you turn, there is his face.
Exactly.
These are not metaphors meant to be taken lightly.
They are absolute statements about the architecture of reality.
God is super
overwhelmingly present.
But if that is true, you are forced to ask a very difficult, very painful question.
Which is, what exactly is this physical, visible world?
I mean, if God is so supremely present, why does the entire architecture of the world we walk through every day seem to stand between us and that presence?
That is the exact friction of this isolation.
If he is everywhere, why do I feel so profoundly separated?
Why does the material world like the ground under our feet, the wooden tables in our homes
the storms in the street, the bodies of the people we talk to, why does all of it feel so undeniably solid, so dense and so opaque?
And that carries a massive emotional weight.
For anyone who actually seeks to understand their place in existence, there is a profound ache built into the fabric of daily life.
It's an ache of separation.
On an ordinary, everyday level, the world feels like a thick, heavy curtain.
When we open our eyes in the morning, what captures our attention is just the sheer solidity of things.
We are captivated, I mean, almost hypnotized by the physical properties of the universe.
It aggressively demands our attention.
Completely.
Think about the energy it takes just to navigate a single day.
You are navigating physical weights, hard surfaces, the absolute need for food, the necessity of shelter.
The commerce of the marketplace.
Yes, the physical exhaustion of your own limbs.
That self-evidence of the physical world demands our constant attention and energy.
Because the world is so undeniably present to our senses, and because it pushes back against us with such force, it makes us feel utterly separated from the Creator.
The crisis is that creation appears to do 2 contradictory things at once.
It screens and it shows.
Exactly.
It's supposed to show God, to act as a book of signs pointing to his majesty, but it simultaneously screens him from our sight.
And on the surface, these two realities seem flatly to cancel each other out.
They really do.
Like if the world is a sign,
Why does it feel like a massive, impenetrable wall?
How can something point to the divine when it is constantly distracting me with its own heavy, demanding presence?
And the fascinating thing about the imam's approach to this agonizing crisis is that he did not try to soften the contradiction at all.
He didn't try to make it easier to swallow.
Not even a little bit.
He didn't try to explain it away with comforting platitudes.
He did not try to make it more comfortable for the rational mind to digest.
Instead, he sharpened it.
He pushed the tension.
He pushed the tension of that paradox to its absolute breaking point to force a breakthrough in how we perceive reality.
The entire focus of our conversation today is to explore how this deeply confusing statement points to a truth that takes the ordinary assumed meaning of the word veil and turns it entirely inside out.
Which is a monumental task because we are so conditioned to think of veils in one very specific way.
Yeah, to begin that process, to really follow his logic, we have to break down our standard baseline assumption about what spiritual life is actually supposed to look like.
Most of us carry a basic intuition, almost
default setting, that the spiritual task is essentially an act of looking past the physical world.
We absolutely do.
We assume the world is a barrier.
It is a curtain hanging in the theater of the cosmos.
We treat it like an obstacle course.
We really do.
We think our job is to push aside the physical reality, to ignore it, to bypass it, or maybe even to despise it in order to find a hidden God who is situated somewhere behind the curtain of existence.
We think we have to escape the physical to reach the spiritual.
Yes.
We create this strict binary.
There is the dirty, heavy, distracting world of things, and then there is the pure, ethereal, invisible world of God.
And the goal is to get out of the former to reach the latter.
Hold on, I have to stop you there because I don't buy that yet.
Calling the veil a revelation or trying to flip this geometry sounds like relabeling the problem, not actually solving it.
Well, if the physical world acts as a barrier to my perception, and we just agreed that it does,
It demands my attention.
It exhausts me.
It pulls my mind away from the divine.
Simply declaring that this barrier is actually a revelation feels like a linguistic trick.
I see what you mean.
It feels like a coping mechanism, honestly.
You were taking the very thing that blocks my vision, the very wall I am banging my head against, and you were trying to tell me it is the source of vision.
How does that actually work?
It sounds contradictory.
Highly contradictory.
How can a physical barrier by its very nature as a limitation
intrinsically reveal anything.
A wall is a wall.
It stops me from seeing what is on the other side.
It still feels like a wall.
That is the exact friction the mind encounters.
That frustration you are expressing is the necessary starting point.
And it is right here at the peak of that frustration that we reach the pivot of the entire philosophy.
Okay.
The Imam provides a startling answer that completely redefines the geometry of this relationship.
We have to change our definition of what a veil actually is.
Okay, let's unpack this.
What is the new definition?
The veil is not an object placed between the creator and the creature.
It's not a curtain.
It is not a curtain.
It is not a wall separating 2 rooms.
The veil is the createdness of the world itself.
The createdness.
Yes, the very createdness.
To be a creature is to be distinct from God.
God is the creator and the thing made is the created.
very distinctness, the simple fact of being a limited, finite, boundaried thing is the veil.
I think I'm following.
God's act of creating something is the act by which it stands apart in its own limited existence.
This apartness, this inherent limitation of being a creature and not being the creator is what we experience as a veil.
And this leads to the spine of the entire metaphysical vision, a truth that we must hold firmly for the rest of this discussion.
The veils do not veil him.
Let's trace the mechanics of that because that is incredibly dense.
If the distinctness of a tree, like the simple fact that a tree is a tree and not God is the veil, then the limitation we experience is not a flaw in the design.
Exactly.
It is the design itself.
The apartness is the very condition of existence for anything that is not God.
Precisely.
If the tree were not limited, if it did not have boundaries, it wouldn't be a tree.
It wouldn't exist as a distinct entity at all.
Its limitation is its existence.
So the wall isn't an obstacle placed in front of the tree.
The tree is the wall by virtue of being a tree.
But we still have the problem of how a wall reveals.
How does the limitation act as a window?
Let's use an analogy to make this transparent because the human mind needs something tangible to grasp this.
Think of a written word on a piece of paper.
Imagine A handwritten letter from someone you love deeply.
Okay, I am picturing the ink on the page.
The physical ink on that page hides the speaker.
The ink is not the speaker.
It is just a chemical mark, a dark shape formulated from soot and water sitting on a flat surface.
In that strictly physical sense, the ink stands totally apart from the living, breathing mind that conceived the message.
The ink has no heartbeat.
It has no consciousness.
It is dead matter.
It is completely other than the author.
And yet, it simultaneously reveals the speaker.
It reveals the speaker perfectly, precisely because it carries their exact intent, their precise meaning, their voice.
Now think about two different people looking at that same piece of paper.
To someone who cannot read the language, let's say they only know the alphabet of another tongue, they look at the page and what do they see?
They just see shapes.
Squiggles and lines.
Exactly.
To someone looking only at the physical properties, the marks are an opaque barrier.
They are just dark shapes blocking the clean white space of the paper.
They're trapped.
The illiterate observer is staring at the ink.
The ink is a veil that completely hides the author because the observer is trapped by the sheer physicality of the chemical marks.
They might admire the calligraphy, they might weigh the paper, but they are entirely separated from the meaning.
But to someone who can read.
To someone who can read the.
are pure transparency.
The reader does not look at the ink.
The reader looks through the ink to the meaning.
When you read a letter from a loved one, you do not sit there marveling at the chemical composition of the black lines.
You hear their voice in your head.
You feel their emotion.
You understand their mind.
The physical limitation of the ink, the fact that it is just a shape on a page, is the exact and only vehicle that delivers the infinite depth of their message to you.
The ink hides the author because it's not the author, but it reveals the author because it carries their meaning.
Exactly.
And the heart that is polished by remembrance learns to read the physical world in this exact way.
The physical world is the ink.
The heart learns to read the trees, the stones, the struggles of daily life, the changing of the seasons as words written by the Creator.
It does not destroy the physical world to find God.
Because that would be absurd.
You do not scrape the ink off the page to find the author's meaning.
What A profound way to put it, yes.
If you scrape the ink off the page to get to the hidden author behind it, you destroy the very revelation you are seeking.
You are left with a blank page and no message.
That's a powerful image.
The aesthetic impulse to entirely destroy the physical world, to despise the body, to hate the material existence is like scraping the ink off the page.
The polished
heart reads the ink, it sees the physical limitation as the precise vehicle of the divine meaning.
That really transforms the emotional ache we discussed earlier.
The ache, that agonizing feeling of separation we experience in our daily lives, comes from being illiterate to the signs.
Precisely.
When we look at a landscape or a difficult task or another human being,
and we feel separated from the divine, it is because we are staring at the ink.
We are fixated on the chemical marks.
We are fixated on the husk.
We are obsessing over the font while ignoring the story.
Exactly.
The separation is real, just as the ink is genuinely separate from the author.
The ink is not the author, but the separation is the vehicle of the meaning.
The veil is the revelation.
We can deepen this by looking at two faces of 1 reality.
The Islamic tradition expresses this through the divine names, the apparent and the hidden.
Okay, let's look at those.
These are two names of God that frame everything we are talking about.
God projects A self-disclosure, what philosophers call a theophany, through the creation.
And we should clarify what theophany means in this context, just to keep it grounded.
It simply means God putting his own attributes on display.
It is the act of showing.
Every single created thing, every atom, every galaxy, every drop of rain is a face of the apparent.
It is the manifestation of what can be shown.
Creation does not exist on its own account.
It has no independent reality.
None at all.
It has no independent, isolated reality.
It exists entirely by virtue of the divine reality it projects.
The world is God making himself apparent.
The distinction between the apparent and the hidden is crucial here.
If creation is the face of the apparent, it means the physical world is not competing with God for reality.
Yes, that's a key distinction.
It is not an alien substance that God has to fight against or push through.
The world is the outward projection of God's own desire to be known.
We can visualize this with a second analogy, one that moves from the page to the sky.
Think of light streaming out from a fiercely luminous source.
Like the sun?
Like the sun.
The creation is like that pouring light.
Imagine a single beam of light breaking into a dusty room.
That light perfectly discloses the source.
It tells you everything.
It tells you everything about the radiance, the warmth, the brilliance of the source.
It is the evidence of the source.
But here is the critical part.
It does this without ever emptying or diminishing the source.
The sun does not become less bright because it illuminates room.
The hidden remains the inexhaustible, uncreated depth.
Exactly.
The hidden is the core that never diminishes no matter how much light is poured outward into the universe.
The hidden is the essence of God, completely beyond human comprehension, completely untouched by the limitations of time and space.
So the apparent is the projection.
The apparent is the outward projection of that light into the theater of existence.
The light we see is the apparent.
The blinding core we cannot look directly at is the hidden.
This brings us directly to the scriptural foundation, which ties this all together perfectly.
These 2 names are not just philosophical concepts.
They are spoken in a single breath in the Quran.
Yes, they are.
We read in chapter 57, verse 3.
He is the first and the last, the outward and the inward, and he has knowledge of all things.
The outward and the inward, the apparent and the hidden.
Holding those dualities together is the only way the world makes sense.
He's the outward, the apparent, meaning the visible universe, the heavy, dense, opaque world we struggle with, is actually his self-disclosure.
It is the light hitting the dust.
And he is the inward, the hidden, meaning his absolute essence remains forever beyond our grasp.
If we split those two realities, if we only focus on the outward without recognizing it as a projection of the inward,
The world becomes an opaque wall again.
It becomes just a room full of dust.
This exact pairing of the outward and the inward became the absolute hinge for an entire tradition of reading the world.
We can look to the Fatimid poet, a towering figure who taught that every outward form in existence is essentially a husk enclosing an inner reality.
The husk and the kernel.
Yes.
Whether it is a verse of scripture, a physical object in nature, or an event in your own life, it possesses an outward surface and an inward depth.
To move from the letter to the meaning, to move from the husk to the kernel, the intellect must engage in a practice historically called tawil, the inner interpretation.
It is a rigorous movement of the mind and the heart.
The intellect's task is not to destroy the husk.
You do not smash the physical world.
You do not hate the husk because the husk protects the kernel.
Just like you don't scrape the ink off the page.
Precisely.
Instead, you use the inner interpretation to crack the husk open to reach the meaning.
It means taking a thing back to its origin.
You trace the light back to the source.
You look at the physical limitation of the object.
You recognize it as a word spoken by the apparent, and you follow that word back to the hidden silence from which it emerged.
That inner interpretation is a profound shift in how we live.
reversal of the outward projection.
Beautifully said.
If creation is God speaking a word, the inner interpretation is the human being hearing that word and tracing the sound back to the silence.
It requires a fundamental shift in perception.
It means looking at the heavy, demanding world not as a series of obstacles, but as a series of invitations.
And no one pressed this mystery harder or with more beautiful provocation than the Aphorist.
He meditates on this mystery through a cascade of rhetorical questions that challenge our basic, lazy assumptions about what a veil even is.
He really tears down those illusions.
What does he ask?
He strips away the illusion of the veil layer by layer simply by asking the mind to consider the logical
of a creation hiding its creator.
He asks, how can something veil him when he manifests everything?
Think about that.
That's A staggering thought.
If God is the light by which you see the veil, how can the veil hide him?
He goes on.
How can a veil exist when he was manifest before the existence of everything?
The timing alone shatters the idea.
Exactly.
How can a temporary limited thing hide the eternal limitless source that sustains its very existence in that exact moment?
The sheer wonder of the contingent world standing alongside
eternity is staggering when you actually pause to observe it.
The aphorist forces us to realize that seeing the veil at all means you are already seeing by his light.
Contingency is a great word here.
The world is contingent.
It relies entirely on something else to exist.
It cannot hold itself up.
Right.
The fact that you can perceive a boundary, the fact that you can perceive A limitation, a tree, a stone, a letter on a page, means you are perceiving the divine act of limitation.
Yes, the very act itself.
Existence of the veil is the undeniable proof of the power that manifested it.
A shadow proves the light.
So the contingent world, this temporary fragile world of things that we bump into every day, is held in existence alongside the eternal.
It doesn't block the eternal.
It is suspended within it.
is a marvel.
But the mind struggles with this marvel.
It is dizzying.
The rational mind, which likes neat categories and solid walls, rebels against this.
And that leads to a necessary challenge, a real friction we have to address.
And I am going to push back again because my rational mind is rebelling right now.
That sounds like wordplay.
Does it?
I am sorry, but it does.
If everything reveals God, if the ink is the revelation of the author, what does the word veil?
even mean anymore?
If there is no hidden God behind the curtain, if the curtain itself is the revelation, aren't we just equating the world with God?
That is the danger.
That is the cliff edge we are walking on.
It's a massive cliff.
I mean, if every tree, every star, every stone, every physical object is a manifestation of the apparent, aren't we dangerously close to saying the universe itself is divine?
which entirely collapses the very distinction between the creator and the created.
If the tree is God making himself apparent, am I supposed to worship the tree?
That is the most important danger to address in this entire deep dive.
It is the exact trap that many spiritual seekers fall into when they first encounter this profound nearness.
And it brings us to the foundational sentence from the imam's teaching.
What is the guardrail here?
This specific logic protects the entire vision from collapsing into pantheism.
It is the ultimate guardrail.
The imam states, he is with everything but not in physical nearness.
And he is other than everything but not in physical separation.
That is a dense, incredibly tightly wound sentence.
Let's examine the mechanics of that carefully.
Let's take the first half.
He is with everything but not in physical nearness.
Yes.
This establishes imminence, presence.
God is intimately present with the tree, with the stone, with the ink on the page.
The withness.
But, and this is the God rail, not in physical nearness.
He is not mixed into the material of the world.
He's not a physical substance blending with another physical substance, like sugar dissolving in water.
He is with the tree, but he is not the wood.
He is with the ink, but he is not the soot.
And the second-half.
He is other than everything, but not in physical separation.
This establishes transcendence, distinctness.
God is absolutely, completely other than the tree.
He is uncreated.
The tree is created.
He is infinite.
The tree is finite.
So he isn't the object itself.
But, and here's the other guardrail, not in physical separation.
He is not pushed away into a distant galaxy.
He is not sitting on a cloud a billion light years away.
He is distinctly other, but intimately near.
This brings us to the stakes of getting this wrong, because if you lean too far toward either half of that sentence, the whole spiritual architecture collapses.
Exactly.
And the metaphysician explains the severe stakes of maintaining this balance.
There are two fatal errors on the spiritual path, 2 traps that the human mind constantly falls into because we struggle to hold these two truths together.
The first trap is the error of collapse.
Which leads to idolatry.
It is the absolute root of idolatry.
This happens when you stress God's nearness, his imminence so much that the creator and the creature dissolve into one another.
You blur the line, you make God finite, you trap him in a physical boundary.
You start worshiping the objects.
You look at the beauty of the light hitting the dust and you worship the dust.
the ink for the author.
The error of collapse is deeply tempting.
We have to acknowledge why humans do this.
We want something tangible to hold onto.
Our bodies crave physical touch.
Our eyes crave physical beauty.
It's natural to want that.
We want a God we can measure, a God we can touch, a God we can put in our pocket or build a shrine around.
But the moment we do that, we have lost the infinite.
We have trapped the limitless in a cage of our own making.
That is the idolatry of the ancient world.
But it is also the idolatry of the modern mind when we worship nature or human intellect or the physical universe itself.
So what is the second trap?
The second trap is the error of exile.
This happens when you stress God's transcendence so much, you stress his otherness so much, that God is pushed entirely out of the world.
A total separation.
You emphasize his incomparability to such an extreme degree that you leave behind a mute, empty, mechanical universe.
You say, God is so holy, so distant, so pure, that he has nothing to do with this dirty physical world.
And the result of that is devastating.
It is absolute isolation.
The world is stripped of its signs.
The ink on the page is no longer
letter from a loved one.
It is just random chemical marks in a chaotic universe.
Humanity is left isolated in a mechanical void, overseen by an absent clockmaker who wound the universe up and walked away.
Okay, I have to concede the logic here.
I was pushing back hard against the idea that the veil is the revelation, fearing it would lead to worshiping the world.
But I see the guardrail now, and it hinges entirely on grasping the non-numerical oneness of God.
Let's explore that.
What do you mean by non-numerical oneness?
Well, this is the crucial distinction that solves my earlier frustration.
If God were simply one in the numerical sense, like one apple sitting on a table or one king ruling a kingdom, then the existence of the universe would mean there are now two things.
God and the universe.
Right, apple and orange, king and subjects.
Exactly.
There would be two distinct objects sitting side by side.
There would be rival realities competing for space and existence.
If the universe takes up space, it pushes God out.
If God takes up space, he crushes the universe.
That's the spatial dilemma.
But because God is infinite, because his oneness is absolute and non-numerical, the created world cannot be a rival reality.
Infinity plus one is still infinity.
That is such an important mathematical analogy.
The existence of the contingent world doesn't add to God and it doesn't subtract from him.
It's apparent otherness isn't a literal physical wall shutting God out.
It is simply his self showing.
The veil only becomes opaque.
It only becomes a dark, frustrating barrier when we fail to hold his imminence and his transcendence together in our minds.
Beautifully said.
To hold those opposites together, to see the ink and hear the author simultaneously is the very definition of spiritual vision.
It is the ultimate goal.
The early Sufi was once asked a profound question.
He was asked how he came to know God, and his answer cuts right to the heart of everything we were discussing.
He answered through the fact that he brings opposites together.
Through the holding together of contradiction.
Yes.
The polished heart can hold together what the rational mind must tear apart.
The rational mind, governed by logic and geometry, looks at transcendence and immanence and sees a flat contradiction.
It sees a paradox that cannot be solved.
It says you cannot be far and near at the same time.
But the polished heart looks at those same 2 realities and sees the single breathing reality of existence.
It is not a logical demonstration.
It is a direct witnessing.
But here's where we hit a massive practical problem.
All of this metaphysical vision, this beautiful soaring architecture of thought, but the apparent and the hidden, the ink and the author, the light and the dust.
It is completely useless if it remains an idle theory.
You're getting to the core of the issue.
It is a wonderful philosophical edifice to marvel at, but how does the listener actually polish the heart to see this way?
Because right now, my heart is not polished.
I still get frustrated by the heavy, opaque world.
We all do.
The eye does not cure its own blindness just by understanding the theory of light.
What is the mechanism of transformation?
This is the most vital question.
We have to move from theory to practice, from philosophy to the quintessence of worship.
we are talking about is not granted by reading a book.
It is grown only in a specific, grueling discipline.
A discipline of the heart.
Yes.
And the scriptural commands in the Quran regarding this discipline are incredibly explicit and incredibly frequent.
In chapter 76, verse 25, we are told, invoke the name of your Lord morning and evening.
That sets a daily rhythm.
In chapter 33, verse 41, the command is, invoke God with much invocation.
And in chapter 7, verse 205,
We are instructed.
Invoke your Lord within yourself, beneath your breath.
The emphasis there is incredible.
The key operating word running like a steel thread through all of these commands is abundance.
It is not a suggestion for occasional polite reflection.
It is a demand for continuous abundant invocation.
The requirement of abundance is so revealing because it provides A diagnosis of the human condition.
Why must the invocation be abundant?
Why isn't it enough to just think about God once a week or once a day?
What's the diagnosis?
Because the natural default state of the human mind as it wanders through the heavy physical world is forgetfulness.
Spiritual amnesia.
We are constantly gravitatingly drawn back to the surfaces.
We are drawn back to the weight, the color, and the stress of the veil.
Which brings us to our third analogy, and it perfectly captures this diagnosis.
The heart forgets as a matter of second nature, just as an untended blade inevitably gathers rust.
Let's dive deep into that image.
Think of a blacksmith forging a blade.
He heats the metal, he strikes it, he polishes it until it shines like a mirror.
It can reflect the sun perfectly.
A flawless surface.
But if you take that highly polished sword and leave it exposed to the open air, the oxidation process begins immediately.
It doesn't wait.
The oxygen in the air begins to bond with the iron, creating rust.
And a medicine taken once does not cure a chronic condition.
Exactly.
Spiritual amnesia is our chronic condition.
The physical world is the air that oxidizes the heart.
The heavy, demanding, opaque nature of daily life is constantly rusting our spiritual vision.
So we need continuous polishing.
In vacation, the remembrance of the name must be continual because the rusting of the heart is continual.
The moment you stop polishing the blade, the rust begins to form.
You cannot polish the sword on a Friday and expect it to shine brightly the following Thursday if you have left it out in the rain.
The physical reality of rust is such a hauntingly perfect image for the creeping opacity of the world.
Because rust doesn't happen all at once.
It's gradual.
A polished blade doesn't turn brown and flaky in a single second.
It loses its gleam slowly, imperceptibly.
First it just looks slightly dull, then a small spot appears, then another.
Until one day, it is entirely coated in rust and it can no longer reflect the sun at all.
The continuous invocation is the only friction that keeps the metal clear.
This necessity for constant, unyielding practice is captured perfectly in the instruction from the prophet.
A man approached him one day.
This man was overwhelmed by the sheer number of religious duties, the complex laws, the myriad requirements of the faith.
He was drowning in the details.
He felt burdened, exhausted by the effort of trying to keep track of it all.
He asked the prophet for a single comprehensive practice, one core thing he could hold onto to anchor his soul.
And what did the prophet give him?
He gave him a remarkably physical, immediate remedy.
He told the man, let your tongue never cease to be moist with the remembrance of God.
The physicality of that instruction is absolutely striking.
It is a perpetual moistening.
It isn't just a mental exercise.
No, not at all.
The prophet didn't say, let your mind dwell on high thoughts.
He didn't say, engage in abstract silent meditation.
He pointed to the tongue.
He pointed to saliva, to the vocal cords, to the physical movement of the body.
It is an ongoing bodily devotion.
to the name of God.
It grounds the infinite in the physical body.
Yes, the physical act of moving the tongue, the breath carrying the name, the subtle vibration in the chest.
This physical action becomes the constant counter friction to the constant rusting of the heart.
The medicine in motion.
The name of God is itself the cure, and taking the cure requires the body's active, continuous participation.
But, you know, introducing this continuous, formless practice often raises a significant defense from the structured, rational mind.
The ego is very clever, and it will use even spiritual concepts to avoid hard work.
I can hear the objection forming already.
If this remembrance is so continuous and formless, if it is something I can do while standing, while sitting, while walking through the noisy marketplace, while doing my daily chores, isn't that just a very convenient excuse to abandon the difficult, rigid discipline of formal ritual prayer?
That's the loophole people look for.
It is very easy, almost seductive, for someone to say, look, my tongue is moist with remembrance.
I am remembering God in my heart while I go about my day, so I don't need the rigid constraints
of specific prayer times.
I don't need to perform the physical bows and prostrations.
My whole life is a prayer.
That is exactly how the ego attempts to co-opt the practice.
It uses the boundlessness of the remembrance to escape the discipline of the law.
But the scripture defines the relationship between the two very carefully, and they are not in competition.
They work together.
The Quran states in chapter 29, verse 45, that formal prayer keeps one from iniquity, but the remembrance of God is greater.
Greater.
We have to unpack what greater means here, because it doesn't mean a replacement for.
No, it does not.
Formal prayer acts as a vital preventative.
It fences the soul against its worst impulses.
It provides an indispensable architectural structure to the day.
It breaks up the monotony of time.
A framework.
But a fence is, by definition, a limitation.
It happens at specific times.
You face a specific direction.
You say specific mandated words.
It is bounded.
And because it is bounded, if that is the only thing a person relies on,
Their connection to God becomes bounded as well.
That is the danger of relying solely on the form.
They feel near to God only when they're on the prayer mat, standing in a sacred space.
And the moment they step off that mat, the moment they walk back into the noise of the market or the stress of their home, they are back in the secular, opaque world.
The fence protects the garden, but it does not permeate the rest of the landscape.
Exactly.
The formal prayer is the vessel, but what goes inside it.
This is why the limitless practice is required.
The fifth imam noted that everything in religious law has a limit at which it stops.
Fastening ends when the sun goes down.
Yes.
Prescribed duties finish when their conditions are met.
Charity has a calculated amount.
Every formal requirement has a boundary, an endpoint, except one thing.
The remembrance of God.
It has no boundary.
It has no time limit.
It has no designated location.
The remembrance does not abolish the formal prayer.
It is the greater substance that pours into the vessel of formal prayer.
And then it overpours.
And then, because it is boundless, it spills out of that vessel to fill every ordinary hour of life.
The lesser is not left behind.
It is completed by the greater.
Exactly.
The continuous invocation ensures that the intense awareness generated inside
formal prayer is carried over.
It is carried into the marketplace, into the home, into the silence of the night.
It is the thread that strings the pearls of formal prayer together so the day becomes a single necklace of presence.
So the continuous practice, the moist tongue, the constant polishing of the blade, this is the physical mechanism that allows a human being to maintain the vision of the veil that reveals
rather than falling back into the nightmare of the veil that hides.
It is the only way.
The polished heart is maintained entirely by the moist tongue.
And this brings us to the radical turn.
This is the final and undoubtedly the most vertiginous teaching of the Imam.
It is a teaching that forces us to look entirely past ourselves.
Which is the hardest thing of all.
Everything we have discussed so far, the inner interpretation, tracing the light to the source, the careful balance of immanence and transcendence,
The continual moistening of the tongue to polish the rusting heart, all of it assumes one very basic thing.
It assumes there is a self who is doing the invoking.
Yes.
It assumes there is a person, an individual ego, a distinct entity holding the polish and applying it to their own heart.
And that is the baseline of our entire lived experience.
When I invoke the name, I am the one remembering.
I am the reader looking at the ink.
I am the observer watching the light.
There's God and there is me trying to remember him.
But the imam dismantles even that baseline assumption.
He really tears down the final wall.
He strips it all the way down to the studs.
He says that one does not truly remember God until one forgets one's own soul in the remembrance.
Let that sink in for a moment.
Forgetting one's own soul, that is the ultimate effacement of the self.
It is absolute extinction.
At the summit of this practice, the individual who set out so earnestly to remember God realizes A terrifying and beautiful truth.
Their own separate ego, their sense of me doing the remembering was the final, most stubborn veil.
The polished mirror becomes so incredibly clear, so perfectly devoid of rust or distortion, that the glass itself disappears from view.
You no longer see the mirror, you only see the reflection.
Perfect remembrance requires the total extinction of the individual who is doing the remembering.
At the absolute peak of invocation, the one who invoked vanishes.
It's all burned away.
The illusion of an independent, separate self is burned away in the fire of the name.
Only the name remains.
It is the ultimate confirmation of our entire thesis.
When the self is effaced, when the heavy demanding ego is finally laid down, we arrive exactly where we began, but with total clarity.
We see the world as it truly is.
And what is that truth?
We state it again, for the final time, the spine of the entire vision.
The veils do not veil him.
The world remains.
The trees are still trees.
The ink is still on the page.
The individual physical forms still walks the earth.
But it is no longer misread as a solid, opaque wall.
The rust is gone.
The creation is entirely transparent to the source.
And so we turn directly to you, the listener, with an unresolved challenge to carry forward into the reality of your own week.
This is not just theory.
This is about how you perceive the weight of your own life, which surface in your own life, which frustrating task, which difficult person, which physical exhaustion are you still mistaking for the whole of things?
And what would beginning the small continual remembrance actually cost you this week?